Hey, I'm Jarrod and
I'm a course developer for
the iOS team here at Udacity.
>> And I'm Brynn, an Android coach and
a developer of the Android
interviewing course.
>> In just a moment you'll be
watching a mock interview for
a mobile development job.
>> This will give you an opportunity to
watch the rules of both an interviewer
and an interviewee.
>> Now,
when it comes to an interview for
a mobile development job there are some
things that you want to keep in mind.
Generally speaking, most mobile
development teams are pretty small.
Sometimes it might even
be just one person.
So you'll want to prepare for
all aspects about development.
That includes designing user interfaces,
researching APIs,
implementing and testing,
debugging, the whole gamut.
>> But don't let that be a deterrent
Interviewers like to see your code.
So if you haven't already it's a great
idea to have your projects available and
get help or
somewhere that can be easily accessed.
>> Absolutely.
And you should be prepared to answer
questions about your code like, how did
you architect this project or what
was the biggest technical challenge?
Remember, each question the interviewer
asked is an opportunity to let
your experiences shine.
>> Now, without further ado,
let's hear from our interviewer and
see what they're looking for
in a candidate.